what's up people Ryan right in the house
and Jerry in the backyard
here we go today we're gonna talk about
Mad Max a fury road official trailer
number dos some haters think that you
know we just pump up the volume of our
voices in order to get more views cuz
you know like we're trying to
entertaining is there a direct
correlation between loudness and views
okay we'll just scream so that way we
can get a thumbnail watch here's the
thumbnail but it needs to be during the
reaction all right anyway jerry has seen
the trailer did I watch the [ __ ] out of
this this morning you dug it in jurdy
yeah I'm so excited
we'll get the fresh eye and the nuts and
then now that I've seen this trailer
again here is what I am my entire
opinion I don't like it here we go here
we go Mad Max he's back he's furious
he's ready to go fast he's gonna be the
next installment of that's the beer it's
actually that kind of work it was weird
Elseworlds thing
displace love
to a single instant
survive
this affects an awesome
well this section
a little black boy
oh what a day what a lovely day we'll
get through this
Wow
each of us in our own way was broken
was more crazy
me
one else
Wow heads are
oh [ __ ] here
[ __ ] yeah man that looks how [ __ ]
good does that look
looks so awesome looks so [ __ ] good I
love it for all the right reasons I just
feel really hot right now I know you
just really need to drink after you go
to this end and it's a combination of it
actually being hot in here right now
voila - yeah full-on immersive
experience not exactly the finest way to
watch this trailers in the sauna
that's real IFD apocalyptic world the
coolest [ __ ] designs a [ __ ]
terrifying villain well that's it was
your find a world yeah so I need them
all of those dudes it's committed so
much to the madness and everything that
is it looks so [ __ ] appealing about
it the designs are awesome it's like all
the practical effects are great in the
CGI effects look good - well I'm just
super excited cuz it's like this
franchise like George Miller's baby and
it seems it just seems so cool that like
they've clearly given him everything to
work with yeah they're letting him do it
the way he wants to do it well at least
that's what the trailer represents yeah
I was watching this I'm like they just
don't make movies like this in the hour
and I'm so excited for that cuz it just
looks you know hot and gritty and weird
just like those movies always were this
is that case where it's like okay yeah
they're revamping the franchise but
they're bringing back the original
director and writer like I mean it's his
vision I think that's Orange Miller okay
we all got a little bit let down when
George Lucas returned with episode 1
right and then Stephen Stover returned
for Indiana Jones for we [ __ ] got
this guy to do it and there's like no
one else that could do it yeah like that
it commits so much to this totally crazy
world man we'll see that's the thing is
like I almost feel like we're the Star
Wars or Star Trek or one of those you
know they've got all these new movies
coming on they've got all these
different directors and for some reason
that works for me but like Mad Max I
feel like if you had a different
director and this was just a reboot it
would probably not be all that good
maybe it much more toned down yeah it's
like you've got the guy yeah and it's
gonna be as wild as yeah I mean these
movies are always a little slower than
the trail like the trailers have you
believe like because they're always kind
of desolate that way when still like
antsy
it seems like he's really approaching it
the right way like I've heard that a lot
of practical braking cars and blowing
shuts that's honestly what looks amazing
about it so it seems like he knows where
to do crazy cg windstorm and then you
know real to nick buckets and bolts
crashing I love seeing an actor who we
normally don't see transform transform
Optimas premiering this whole Nicholas
Hoult man that's what was so [ __ ] cool
about him doing that Tom Hardy you gotta
hear his voice test sexy [ __ ] voice
yelling frozen if you turn to sexy boys
for this no.1 Charlize Theron looks
badass
his voice kids be Tom Hardy you know
what I mean and then I'm moment with
Charlize Theron just really where she's
about to headbutt a guy I immediately
thought wow this movie's gonna be really
violent
- totally it's gonna I mean it just
looks so nasty you're not ready to have
oh it's only work when they're really
committed to it though that like The
Devil's Rejects work because of how
committed they were yeah to this
sickening psychopathic family you need
something like a commitment of a
director who's not afraid to go all out
yeah you gotta have a guy who's not
afraid to be ugly and not afraid to be
imposing you know exactly exactly anyway
guys thanks for telling me that trailer
was out if you need to the channel
subscribe subscribe to the real Rieger
oh [ __ ] we're more entertaining where
where you should live is Jerry has a
playlist on this channel you can check
it out two reasons - jerr-bear it's what
I call that [ __ ] man you can follow us
on Facebook Instagram and Twitter where
we tweet pictures of our god oh god it's
not attractive Oh
dony kiss can engine scheming something
interesting now give me that shoutout
and shout-out to you my dear rejects you
get it because in order to earn a
shout-out you have to say something
interesting on the website facebook.com/
slash the real reject shoutouts alright
but nobody can use that trick anymore
I know yeah I was waiting for that joke
yeah forever Joanie Joanie you got it
now says something interest has to be
more interesting than that cuz we're
gonna do for you buddy
yeah we're gonna take a look at how
beautiful you are you look like you own
a music shop like an albums store
doesn't he well like maybe he could play
him like a metal man what do you think
Joanie sounds like oh no yo my name's
Jody what if it's Johnny and it's just
spelled straining Joanie
kiss-kiss can and it's its Arab the
tariff I'm one of them white Arabs that
was born by a family of Arabs I was
dropped off by white people that
neighbor aged me I don't know what this
character is he's the gay white heir
don't have that to represent tell me
that recurring characters on your
episode of working on a monologue right
now for this character
oh okay I love hookah that's usual
that's actually offensive to anybody
because I can't tell if it sounds like